hey guys it's Alicia Malone and you know
you've made it when you have your own
trailer this is pretty cool I'm in
Atlanta Georgia on the set of Allegiant
part 1 and let me tell you from what
I've seen so far this movie is going to
be epic let's check out what's happening
on set so look who I managed to steal
from the set showing Woodley he plays
Tris in the film one thing I always
wonder with these kind of films when you
know that you're gonna be playing one
character for a long time is your
preparation different to other movies no
it's actually it's not I mean other the
nice thing that a film versus like a
television show in my experience is that
you have a start and you have an end and
so you can track the trajectory of the
character but if you look at dresses
life it's the entire series is to spend
a few months how is your connection with
the character defend over the films as
you've been playing for doing more than
one film are you obviously want to try
and you know explore something else in
each different film I'm an explorer
different facet of their personality
said you know some of that comes from
the books been and also you have to make
some choices yourself it's good I get a
lot of like I hate you so much so that's
good that's a good thing you want people
to hate Caleb you know he's not like
those I mean oh I don't really want to
lay them but people don't like him they
say I'm out of what you did in the movie
and that's good you want people to be
mad at this is not the good yeah Peter I
think people really get excited about
because he's fun and I think Peters kind
of only character that really can kind
of comment on the world or comment on
the fact since he has a little humor
which I think is important so I always
enjoy coming back and platinum everyone
we know will die you were right all
along we have to leave that must be
exciting as an actress to come on board
something that is so established your
fans for sure but also like noir
fracking and like you know you feel
pressure like oh that's like this big
big thing and I've never done anything
that big before and like everything is
actually bigger the sets are bigger
they're like more people and
you